last year I recommended iPhone users to
buy the galaxy buds even though there
are certain limitations but a year later
things have changed both for Samsung and
for iOS so today I'll be answering if
the new galaxy buds plus are worth it
for iPhone users and if so what kind of
things do you gain and also miss out on
to get it right out there yes even
though we have the earpods Pro I think
for a lot of iOS users the galaxy buds
might actually be a better buy than air
pods but not for everybody and I'll tell
you exactly why in just a bit last year
I used the Galaxy buds with the nest 10
for about a week before trying it with
my iPhone but this time I skipped
Android altogether and went for a pure
iPhone experience which was made much
easier thanks to Samsung releasing an
iOS app just before launching the buds
plus let's start out with the first
enticement of the buds Plus and that's
the price they officially come in at $50
less than the second gen air pods with
wireless charging but if you buy through
our amazon link in the video description
the difference is only 20 bucks and if
you don't care about wireless charging
the air pots can be had for $10 cheaper
but in a lot of ways the galaxy butts
plus compete more so against the air
pods of pro which I've been happily
using ever since they came out and here
we have a $100 price difference the
second reason you might want to go with
the Galaxy buds plus is the battery life
the originals lasted about an hour more
than the air pods but the plus take it
to a whole nother level being rated at
more than doubled the battery life
thanks to better efficiency and a larger
battery now first I was skeptical about
this reading especially when changing
the EQ but in the real world they do
seem to get very close to that 11th hour
rating now I think most people don't
listen to their music for that long
without taking a break but if you're
somebody that listens for more than five
hours at a time the Galaxy buds will not
limit you at least in terms of battery
now comfort is a different story
personally I find the Galaxy buds to be
less comfortable than either ear pods
but I have heard the opposite from some
people now one thing that I am certain
of is that if you're a very active
person the adjustable wing tips included
give you a very good seal and even
though I don't have
issues with the air pods if you're
somebody that does I think the galaxy
buds will fit better another benefit is
that they don't stick out of your ears
looking like a toothbrush head or a mini
blow dryers so they work better with
hats or helmets if you're using them
like that you might want to use the
ambient mode last year this wasn't
available for iOS but now it is this is
great since the Galaxy buds used a seal
design but unfortunately even though the
ambient mode has gotten better it's
still far behind the pros and with the
air pods unseal design you don't need a
most like that now one thing that
surprised me was how quickly and
consistently they connected last year
they were okay but noticeably worse than
the air pods with the h1 chip but this
year my idea say that sometimes it seems
like they actually pair faster you do
miss out on iCloud integration so you
have to go into the settings of each iOS
or Mac device but the buds plus do
support multiple saved connections and
it will automatically disconnect from my
phone if I select them from my max
Bluetooth menu just like the air pods
now another reason to want the galaxy
buds plus for your iPhone is sound
quality even though they are quieter
than the air pods the buds absolutely
smoke the air pause and actually be out
the air pod pros as well once you tweak
the EQ out of the box they default to
the normal setting but changing that to
dynamic increases the output and bumps
up the mids and the highs while just
slightly decreasing the bass now sound
preferences are definitely subjective
but what isn't are the dual drivers at
the buds plus pack having two speakers
instead of one helps to keep the mids
and highs sounding rich and crisp while
maintaining good quality bass so if you
care about sound quality the galaxy buds
plus sound better and for $100 less one
feature you'll miss out on is the valve
that releases the pressure you get when
using sealed earbuds making them more
comfortable but on the plus side since
they don't have this they seal in most
of the audio whereas the air pods pros
have noticing a more sound leak in the
original ear pods well everybody could
just hear what you're listening to being
that be a seal in here you're
automatically going to block out noise
which air pods will do in our office
this gets rid of the louder than average
HVAC almost as good
as the airport pros active noise
cancellation but for louder noises like
airplanes the air pods do way better one
thing we didn't have to dive in too much
last year was software but now we have
the galaxy Budds app and new software
features through the air pods as well
now I'm glad the iOS users can now use
the AMD mo they could tweak their EQ
they could see their battery settings
for the case in the buds accurately and
you can customize what happens when you
use the controls including having
physical controls for volume which you
can't get with air pods but
unfortunately with an iPhone you're
still gonna miss out on a few features
compared to Android the first is the
gaming mode which lowers latency and
almost matches air pots on iOS since the
Galaxy buds also use AAC there's no lag
when watching videos but when playing a
game sounds will be more than half a
second off compared to just about a
hundred and fifty milliseconds so if you
play a lot of games on your iPhone
that's one area where the buds aren't
worth it the other feature you miss out
on is auto launching Spotify by tapping
on your bun but since you can use Siri
by pressing and holding in the touchpad
after the initial setup you could just
ask Siri to start playing music using
Spotify and that works almost as well in
fact she actually listened right now
when hos recording and turned on Spotify
the one feature you won't get with the
Galaxy buds Plus that I really enjoy is
hands-free Siri which works really well
to change volume launch apps play music
and one specific feature that we didn't
have a year ago which is see reading out
your text messages and allow you to
reply hands-free after I got used to
using hey Siri hands-free and this new
texting feature
I definitely miss it with the galaxy
buds overall if you don't need
hands-free Siri or very low latency in
games I think that the galaxy butts plus
absolutely destroy the original ear pods
especially if you want a sealed fit
I think they compare closer to the pros
than the originals even though they cost
$100 less and you get better sound
quality and battery life you do still
take a trade-off in terms of microphone
quality as you can hear for yourself
right here this are micron quality
during a call with the galaxy's buds
Plus this is a microphone quality during
a call with at the airport
if those Airport features don't matter
to you then the galaxy buds plus are
definitely worth it for iPhone users we
have links to the best deals down in the
video description and go ahead and let
me know what you think down in the
comment section below if you want to see
my full detailed review of the galaxy
buds plus click up there to subscribe
and if you want to see some more great
galaxy buds content we have some right
over there that's Ben Max and I will see
you in the next video
[Music]